let's refresh our memories we have nine
people and what we wanted to do was we
wanted to sort them into these spots two
teams of four ed numpy oh okay
we've looked at this without
restrictions and that was not too
complicated we're introducing this whole
NC k notation in the context of
arrangements
rather than binomial expansions and then
we came to this particular restriction
if two people two particular people
cannot be on the same team okay how many
different combinations are possible okay
now just to refresh your memory
here's now how we started to approach it
okay we said look these two guys who
don't like each other or they're too
good to put on the same team okay we'll
put more different teams so here's why
and he's the other okay so now I've got
less spaces to fill and I have less
objects with which to fill them okay so
do you remember what we did at this
point you can do this in any order you
like okay you can say all right I've got
three spots to fill here and how many
people can I choose from I had nine to
start with I've taken out those two that
gives me seven to choose so I could say
73 that gives me the first team and then
what happened to fill the next team or
choose three again right I think you've
got the loader who ends up one player
one choose one okay now do you remember
what number we got for that
[Music]
140 okay right now the first thing I
labor the point of is that this is a
different scenario to what we did with
no restrictions okay do you remember
what we had no restrictions we over
counted we over counted it because I
might give you say you know by one
number three four five six seven eight
and I'd say look there's one permutation
okay so one combination but if I switch
these guys around exactly like a so
right this is still the same two teams
okay so we had over counted in a
previous situation by a factor of two
two factorial X right okay now do you
remember why am I not in that position
here
you should not divide by two having done
this what's different you can see it
there in its own color okay what was
different in this situation because
there were restrictions I had to deal
with okay I placed these people along
the teams and I locked them into place
okay so now these teams are set I'm not
switching them anymore okay now just
suppose just suppose you say wait wait
you can switch them you know on these
two guys let's call them you know names
like that okay if I did then I have I
have two more wait I've got double the
number of ways to do these teams so then
sure you multiply it by two but if you
want to consider that as a scenario now
I'm back in the position I was before
where I've given you twice as many
arrangements as I sure so then you
should / - right so it doesn't have an
effect the way I always think about it
is if you're over counting because
things can interchange okay when you
lock things in place they're not
interchangeable
anymore so that's why you're not over
counting as it happens in fact we have
undercounted okay we are missing ways of
arranging these teams okay now no one
worked it out yet I want you to come
back with me to the question read it
very carefully you do this over and over
again what are we missing
it's there in the question really with
me if two particular people cannot be on
the same team how many different
combinations are possible to particular
people cannot be on the same team let me
just write that down two people not on
the same team okay now what I've done
what I've done is I've put the two
people on two teams right two people on
two teams two people on two teams I
herein lies the problem which no one is
spotted yet okay these two things these
two things they're not the same they're
not the same if I want them not to be on
the same team there is another way to
not have them on the same team right
that you have them on two different
teams do you see this is why I keep on
writing this even though you're like why
do you write that why do you write that
doesn't make a difference well actually
it does because if I want these two guys
do not be on the same team there's
another way to do it there's another way
I can have one as an umpire and one on a
team now they're not on the same team
right you're happy with that I've
separated the map that's all I needed to
do I think that's why I picked up this
example because this guy over here it
looks so insignificant right and that's
why we even don't write this all the
time my mark
people who do this and I've done this
now I made more choices okay one of the
reasons why I personally when I'm doing
these questions it took me years to work
this out right to make sure I don't miss
anything you write even the things that
seem obvious okay because they'll help
you spot the things then I'm not so
obvious okay so really what this is is
this is case one okay case one is two
people on two different teams okay so
now I'll do case to case two is that
I'll make one the umpire and I'll make
the other one on one of the teams okay
does that make sense now you can think
through it if I make one the umpire I'm
gonna draw boxes again
okay I'm gonna lock in it so here he is
it's done okay now I think about that
other important player the Astor's
player okay how many places can I put
you
okay now in terms of teams I can put him
in two different teams I can put him in
either team or in terms of spots I can
put him in eight spots the point is now
I've got this guy away from the other
guy there are actually no more
restrictions on how I place right
because I've already satisfied this it's
done okay so I don't need another
asterisk on my on my arrangement to
account for the restriction
automatically they are on different
teams now so now I proceed to you may
I've got four slots to fill how many
people can I fill it with eight I have
eight left I had nine then I took up one
right so now I've got eight shoes full
okay
is that right and then I have to fill
Team B right which is four people there
she's four of them by the way what sport
shoes for one because well I don't know
where else to put them do I
okay and you can work this out I'm
pretty sure it's set anyways okay I
choose four I think it's 17 you can even
think of that Road in Pascal's triangle
okay so therefore your total number of
ways arranging to meet this condition is
case 1 plus cases in the total is 210
degrees okay
by the way one last thing nothing is
that important but just so you know you
probably appreciate the fact that
there's always lots of different ways to
do questions right just have a look at
this line the one we established
yesterday okay
I went from left to right from left to
right and um I left the oh the umpires
the pool I'm privileged super right but
it doesn't necessarily have to be maybe
you think actually picking out the
umpire is the most important rather than
the least important
so then how would I rewrite it I would
say okay first I need to put someone in
the umpire spot right for this case so I
would say how many do I have to choose
strong hold on hold on
I'm already placed a restriction on this
have a place which it so seven it's
seven choose one right and then I'll go
over to this team how many do I have
left
I've got six another choose three right
and now this team over here it becomes
that I've got no more choices option it
becomes three issues three which is just
one right and then you get it get your
calculator and you say well what years
so here just out okay are you you can
pull your range anticipate what seven
choose one is going to be just a seven
right so then you go well what seeks
choose three and you're like oh oh it's
twenty right it's still up at seven
forty ways it's the same situation you
just looked at it from a different angle
okay